good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Elizabeth Bradley and on behalf
of the New York Public Library welcomed
Celeste Bartos forum it is my great
pleasure to introduce Amanda Smith who
will be interviewed this evening by Sam
Roberts on the subject of her
grandfather Joseph P Kennedy and the
challenges of reconstructing a life from
a lifetime's worth of letters both
public and private Amanda Smith is the
author of hostage to fortune the letters
of Joseph P Kennedy a loving lucidly
edited compilation of her grandfather's
letters that seeks and succeeds in
giving a voice to a figure which had
heretofore been felt as an influence but
perhaps not understood as an actor in
many of the national and international
dramas of the past century hostage to
fortune has been hailed as a remarkable
self-portrait a goldmine for future
biographers and a frank and fruitful
trek through the vast ephemera of Joe's
encounters with world leaders a trove of
materials and honest and compelling
collection bearing all these accolades
in mind you'll probably not be surprised
to hear that Miss Smith is also a
doctoral candidate in the English
department of Harvard University from
which she also holds bachelor's and
master's degrees I can think of no
better journalist better suited to the
task of interviewing Miss Smith about
her book and it's subject on sam roberts
mr. roberts is the deputy editor of the
new york times Week in Review section
and the host of New York close-up on New
York one news he's the co-author of
Michael with Michael Kramer of I never
wanted to be vice president of anything
an investigative biography of Nelson
Rockefeller and the author of who we are
a portrait of America based on the
latest US census is also added an
anthology of stories for children drawn
from the New York Times and his latest
book an inside story of the Rosenberg
spy case is entitled Greenglass the
final confession and will be published
in September at the conclusion of their
interview miss Smith will take questions
from the audience of our time permits
please use the microphones at the side
of the stage they're located sides of so
you can be heard you all have heard me
give this feel before but it's very hard
for this speaker to hear you if you
don't use the mic
phones and now ladies and gentlemen
won't you please join me in welcoming
Amanda Smith and Sam Roberts to the New
York Public Library Thank You Betsy and
thanks to all of you for coming tonight
we're going to just have a conversation
and then invite you to join in later on
and as Betsy said if when we take
questions you go up to the microphones
we'd be happy to field whatever kind of
questions you choose to ask as Betsy
said Amanda Smith is a student at
Harvard getting her doctorate degree
she's the daughter of Jean Kennedy and
Steven Smith Jean Kennedy was the eighth
child of Joe Kennedy and Rose Kennedy
she found out about this trove of Joe
Kennedy memorabilia these letters this
archival collection a number of years
ago found them in a warehouse in Queens
found them in an office on Third Avenue
found them in the Attic above the
bedroom of her grandfather's house in
Massachusetts and pored through more
than 600,000 pages of letters and other
documents to come up with hostage to
fortune the name of the book comes from
a radio address that Joe Kennedy
delivered on behalf of Franklin D
Roosevelt in 1940 and he said if I can
find it here I have a great stake in
this country my wife and I have given
nine hostages to fortune his nine
children Amanda what do you think he got
in return for giving those nine hostages
what was Joe Kennedy looking for well in
terms of them I think he had a very
distinctive plan for his children and
some people have said that it amounted
living vicariously through them and
living out his own presidential
aspirations but if you talk to his own
children often what they say is that he
was a very demanding father also a very
loving father but all that he demanded
of his children was that they cultivate
their own particular talents and
interests to the highest possible degree
um and I think in terms of Nine Hostages
to fortune that's one of the reasons
obviously that I chose the name for the
book and he was somebody Joe Kennedy was
somebody who toured an extraordinary
degree
um controlled his own destiny but
couldn't obviously control the fact that
some of the most important and most
precious things in his life his children
particularly young Joe Kennedy and
Kathleen were taken from him in ways
that were absolutely beyond his control
and in terms of I chose this is the
title also because it relates to his
reasons for supporting Franklin
Roosevelt originally in 1932 um not long
after the beginning of the campaign he
said to a reporter um you know basically
my children the most important thing in
the world to me and I feel that um some
modicum of socialism during the Great
Depression and this from a very
conservative capitalist I was the only
thing that would help avoid revolution
in this country and safeguard the the
fortune that he had masked to allow his
children to go on and hopefully
participate in civic life of the country
that had made their advantages possible
so he supported Franklin Roosevelt
preventatively if you will yeah and with
a certain hesitation to him in his
relationship with Roosevelt began on a
very bad note and when Roosevelt during
the First World War when rose wanted out
of the book that rose well actually made
him cry yeah and I think that that the
beginning of their relationship that
began under such hostile terms when
Roosevelt was the Under Secretary of the
Navy and Joe Kennedy was the manager of
a wartime shipyard rose
ordered armed Marines to come and remove
a ship from the Quincy shipyard where he
worked before the Argentine government
had paid for the ships and at that point
my grandfather said Roosevelt was the
toughest negotiator I'd ever come up
against and I broke down on my knees on
the dock that day and began to cry and
over the course of the 30s they they
came to know each other once again when
Roosevelt became a candidate and Joe
Kennedy was brought into the Roosevelt
camp as a very unusual figure I mean he
was one of the few businessmen a few
staunch conservative capitalists who
became part of the Roosevelt camp um but
it was through that political alliance
that they began to sort of have a an
appreciation for one another's talents
and abilities although it's certainly
clear from Joe Kennedy's letters that he
always had reservations about Roosevelt
and was very concerned about who else
might be getting to Roosevelt and
feeding him advice and and the people
around Roosevelt were just as concerned
at least about Joe Kennedy getting to
Roseman yeah absolutely and so he he
took up the jobs at the Securities and
Exchange Commission and at the Maritime
Commission over the course of the 30s um
with a little bit of resentment I mean
certainly they were wonderful posts and
he by most accounts at the time
acquitted himself very admirably but
they weren't really what he had hoped
for him and he throughout his life had
wanted to be the secretary of the
Treasury and his wouldn't say his
nemesis but certainly one of the people
he liked least in the administration was
Henry Morgenthau and who beat him to it
in effect so when the posting came along
in London um he jumped at it and went
and Roosevelt's account of why send an
Irishman to London at a time like that
when war was looming was while it's the
greatest joke in the world with typical
Roosevelt influencing and I'm similar to
when Roosevelt appointed him to head the
Securities and Exchange Commission he
said in effect it takes a thief to catch
a thief yeah
the Fox to guard the chicken coop and
and so Joe Kennedy went to London
believing I'm rightly or wrongly that
Roosevelt had given him a mandate of
absolute US neutrality in the case of
any European war and there's some
question as to whether Joe Kennedy was
reading his own viewpoint into
Roosevelt's parting advice to him but it
was really that issue that broke their
relationship apart and by the time he
gave this address where he described his
children his nine hostages to fortune in
support of Roosevelt's third term
election it really was a defining moment
in the relationship it was the last
thing that Joe Kennedy did on
Roosevelt's behalf he was very angry
very grudging at the time that he made
this speech because he felt that his
power and authority in London had been
subverted and that most of for example
in destroyers for bases negotiations
that had gone on over the course of the
previous year had been carried out
largely through the British Embassy in
Washington rather than through the
American Embassy in London and he knew
for example that Roosevelt and Churchill
were corresponding secretly as we all
know now but he only knew that because
he was to use his own phrase a sort of
glorified errand boy delivering the
messages back and forth between
Churchill and the American Embassy
Amanda what was his real position in
London philosophically he's been accused
of being an anti-semite he's accused of
being an appeaser
he said that Chamberlain and and Pope
Pius the 12th were among his greatest
heroes of course he said that then
without the benefit of hindsight and we
have to take it in that context where
did he really stand peace at any price
keep America out of war no matter what
that was his own philosophy in World War
two did he carried all the way through
in World War one rather did he carry
that all the way through in World War
two also well his own sort of pithy
slogan as to what his viewpoint was in
World War two was all aid to Britain
short of war which is um which is
something that he arrived at over the
course of his ambassadorship he began as
ambassadorship
as a very close friend and a great
admirer of Neville Chamberlain and also
many members of Chamberlain's cabinet
particularly Lord Halifax the foreign
minister at the time and Sir John Simon
who is the Chancellor of Exchequer and
at first that closeness to the cabinet
to the prime minister himself was
actually a very useful thing in
Washington because Kennedy's dispatches
were um you know to quote high-ranking
members of the State Department at the
time the most penetrating that had been
received in years um and actually one
thing that was fascinating to me was
that in press accounts from 1938 and
early 1939 the one thing that he's most
often accused of by members of the press
and politicians across the spectrum in
America was that he was too pro British
to actually carry out his duties
correctly in in the UK and it was
believed that he wouldn't be able to
represent American interest because he
was too taken in by the British and he
came around to believing eventually that
Hitler wouldn't stop with Europe and
actually was the proponent of sending
aid to Britain insofar as we would be
able to spare any during the destroyers
for bases negotiations for example um
but beyond that he really didn't feel
that we should enter the war unless
attacked and he did actually believe
that we'd be attacked but thought that
if the attack would probably come after
the conquest of Europe and and he felt
that the Germans would probably or the
axis in general would probably look
towards the Americas and that the attack
would basically come through South
America and we'd go to war over the
Monroe Doctrine and that assisting
Britain was nothing more than an attempt
to buy ourselves time during our own
rearmament effort and his relationship
with Churchill I think is really
fascinating in this light because um he
was very offended by Churchill's
beautiful rhetoric and celebrating the
common bonds of the english-speaking
peoples ad by his drinking as I he's
drinking he always mentions Churchill's
two-fisted drinking whenever he met him
and and his reasons for that were that
he thought that Churchill was making um
trying to dress up an attempt to
basically rope the United States into
footing the bill for saving the British
Empire and in his accounts of his
meetings with Churchill he often says
you know if Churchill just said that
outright I wouldn't mind so much you
know it would be the right thing for the
United States to do to save the British
Empire but I just think it's
disingenuous of them to talk about all
these highfalutin things and one of the
things that makes the book such great
reading is that you feel you're
eavesdropping on a lot of Kennedy's
conversations on his correspondence of
course some of this is is the result of
self-censorship self-selection one of
his guiding principles throughout his
life was never say anything that you
wouldn't want to see printed on the
front page of the New York Times
well that applied to his letters his
private correspondence as well for the
most part they're no revelations here
they're no lapses here for the most part
that you say my god I can't believe he
wrote that down not so much that I can't
believe he thought that but that he
thought that and wrote it down but what
the letters provide because they're the
raw material is perspective on a lot of
other things that occasionally have been
quoted if you will out of context or
paraphrase because as amanda says and
the editors note the beginning of the
book because of fair use copyright
provisions here we can see it in its
actual unexpurgated form you can see
what Kennedy actually wrote and what he
meant to leave to posterity in that
context there's a fascinating quote at
least I found fascinating from John F
Kennedy in a letter I think to his
father talking about Hitler and he says
that within a few years this is I guess
as the war is about ending within a few
years Hitler will emerge from the hatred
that surrounds him now as one of the
most significant figures who ever lived
what do you think Jack Kennedy meant by
that well there's actually an additional
sentence
beyond that one that you just relic
about quoting that of context where he
does mention that you know certainly he
was nothing short of wholly evil but he
will be one of remembered as one of the
most significant figures in history and
I can only assume that that's what he
meant by it um certainly the children's
letters although Joe Kennedy after 1938
in particular peppers a number of his
diary entries and correspondences with
an anti-semitic remarks and that was
never the case among his children's
letters that I've that I found with one
exception in young Joe's letters but it
was never the case for Jack so I can
only assume given the totality of his
other writings that that's what he meant
that Hitler will be recalled as a very
significant although evil figure you say
in the book that you have one vivid
personal memory of Joe Kennedy when you
went to the house the summer before he
died
summer of 69 what was that memory well I
remember I was about 2 at the time and I
remember being holding the babysitter's
hand and walking across the lawn at the
Cape and my cousin who was about the
same age at the time was there too and
we were both trundling across the lawn
and we were told that we were going to
see grandpa and I remember also hearing
from the conversation that was going on
between the two babysitter's that we
were also going to see mr. Kennedy and
the ambassador and I got very suspicious
that we're gonna actually have to walk a
lot further than I'd originally imagined
so I wasn't looking forward to it and
then I remember being told that we had
to curtsy I had to curtsy because I was
a little girl and my cousin being a boy
had to bow to Grandpa and I remember
being taken into his room and taken to
his bed and he had had a stroke at this
point and this was towards this was in
the last few months of his life
and he had been mute and
unable to move largely since 1961 this
would have been 1969 and the thing that
really amazed me was how although he was
unable to move or speak how much he was
the center of attention in that room I
mean everybody had a sort of whispered
reverence for him and everybody called
him a different name and it was I think
then that I realized that he was many
things to many people
so anyway I was taken over and did my
little curtsy and then went up to kiss
him and I think he was probably the
oldest person that I'd ever seen at that
point in my life and then my cousin went
up and was sort of encouraged to you
know bow to crap I go on bow to Grandpa
and I don't think he knew what anyone
was talking about because the next thing
he did was wind up and launch his little
fist towards grandpa's jongo pow and so
that's really all I remember of him in
my own right now instead of bow yes-uh
it it's interesting that you say in the
book that the aura he created in that
room is more vivid than his own image
that aura that was a reflection of his
personality of a family that as you say
by one counted has had more written
about it than any person or any
phenomenon since Christ and the Civil
War what is it about the American
fascination with the Kennedys you say
that you were quoted in The Times
recently as saying well people see their
own family in the Kennedys but is that
so
do people see such enormous
larger-than-life almost mythological
giant figures in their own family or is
the Kennedy family somehow different
well I think the mythology definitely is
an aspect of it and I think you know if
Joseph Campbell's correct you know we
tend to take modern-day stories and
recast them and familiar tropes and
themes but I think I'll still me from an
English major right
oh yeah um but I think on a more
personal scale a minute
I've never really understood what it is
that makes people so interested but I
can only assume from what people come up
and tell me um particulate events like
this that very often people will say you
know I got such strength from your
grandmother because my own children died
very young or something or um you know I
come from a big family myself and I know
what it means to be a child from a big
family and try and you know get some
attention or make something of yourself
among a big crew of people um and I
found that people seem to relate to them
in an incredibly personal way or even
you know with with my grandfather people
often say to me no I had a very
difficult father myself and um you know
I'm really fascinated with how children
deal with very you know larger-than-life
um
paternal or maternal figures so I can
only assume that people do see something
themselves in them there's sort of an
ambivalence that runs through the book
at least with the introduction it is
sometimes them and it's sometimes us it
sometimes Joe Kennedy and it's sometimes
grandpa which is it for you
I think it's definitely both I mean in
the introduction I tried to use both
because he's both a historical figure Oh
Joe Kennedy and he's also grandpa um and
I think that one of the things
especially in my first memory of him
going to see him and have him discover
that everybody has a different name for
him that that really stayed with me for
the rest of my life and I never quite
could figure out how this person was
that many different things at once I
mean he was when I first learned about
him he was just grandpa and he was the
adored father and grandfather figure
around the house and then as I got older
it began to occur to me that other
people seem to know about him too and as
I went into school I began reading about
him and found out that you know not only
was he
a film producer and financier in
Hollywood the 20s in a banker and I
worked at a shipyard during the first
world war and chairman the SEC in the
Maritime Commission and a British
ambassador our ambassador to Britain but
that he had all sorts of whispered
aspects of his life bootlegger or
anti-semite appease or philanderer
kingmaker that sort of thing and I never
understood how a single life could
encompass all of that and that was the
thing that was very um settling I think
about his letters was that there's
something to all of those roles in his
life and he was that large a figure in
that expansive a figure on the one hand
a very tender very fond father and on
the other hand to use his own expression
very hard-boiled I mean he wasn't
somebody that you'd want to be across
the negotiating table from um and he was
a man of very strong emotions and
affections I mean if he loved you and
you were loyal to him he would be loyal
to you forever and if you crossed him
ever um he was very slow to forgive if
ever um and also had you know held
political views that are very hard to
agree with um but at the same time in
his letters I think it's very hard to
discount him as a monster I mean he um
he was a very significant figure who had
an amazing knack for getting his foot in
the door at the right time and seeing
the next biggest thing and going for it
so he was all of those things at once I
think you said that your additional
impression of him or the impression as
you started this project was that he was
something of a misanthrope
did you change that impression was the
impression bolstered was it softened was
it hardened how did it change in your
research on this book well I'd say that
um I took that impression from reading I
had done about him through the course of
my schooling um and you know certainly a
great deal of research has been devoted
to say his falling out with Roosevelt
and with members of the administration
or with his unpopularity in England and
all of that is certainly well documented
and absolutely true and many
BECs but on the other hand what struck
me about his correspondence was how much
more nuance that created from him and
let's say the broad brushstrokes are
there and well established but he's a
much more subtle figure in my mind than
he ever was before and although he was
somebody who was in a very slow to
forgive anybody crossing him he was also
somebody who had enormous sort of tender
affection and that's something that I
didn't quite expect how what a soft side
he had I've recited that litany of names
that he has had to carry through his
life and after his death the philanderer
anti-semite bootlegger as well as film
producer financier banker kingmaker
other any of those that you would leave
out in retrospect that you would not
apply to Joe Kennedy in retrospect I'd
say again that you know there's there's
something to many of those but I would
say that there's a certain nuance that I
think his own papers and many papers
that are available about him bring to it
and in terms of bootlegging for example
although it's often been said that he
had sort of an enormous and well
organized operation bringing alcohol
into the North Shore of Boston during
the 20s there's no particular indication
that that was true but there is actual
very concrete documentation among his
own papers that um when Prohibition came
into effect in 1920 his father who among
other things was the owner of some
saloons stored their alcohol and one of
the things about prohibition that I'm
sure many of you know is that it didn't
actually make the possession of alcohol
illegal it just made selling it illegal
so the family kept all these stores of
alcohol for their own consumption but
also Joe Kennedy supplied 190 proof
alcohol to his tenth reunion at Harvard
in 1922 and I was reading over the
belief --let's from that were generated
over the course of her the reunion and
apparently said you know Joe Kennedy
we've dubbed him our decennial Santa
Claus cuz I guess he gave him a pretty
good time and
most popular alumnus er yeah something
like that and he showed them a film that
he had recently produced and so there is
something to many of those things but in
terms of the bootlegging and it's not
clear that it was quite on the scale
that it's been made out to be
you say in the book that while I have
some sense of him through his papers my
understanding is bounded eternally by
the fact that I will never know him you
know him through the papers if he were
sitting right here tonight what would
you want to ask um it's a good question
I think I'd ask him what he thought
about this um and the reason I think I
would is that he was certainly somebody
who was very thin-skinned in terms of
accepting criticism from the press or
publicly but on the other hand one of
the most astonishing eye-opening things
to me about finding for example his
diaries in a warehouse in Queens was how
clearly they were intended for somebody
like me eventually to find them and make
use of them I mean there were sort of
editorial notations to me or whoever it
was who would actually find these which
indicated that even in his Diaries which
for many people are their most personal
most intimate accounts of themselves
that they leave behind that he was
thinking of the way that this would be
read by other eyes for posterity and for
example he goes he was the American
representative at the coronation of Pope
Pius the 12th in 1939 and those entries
in his diary are particularly peppered
with you know I spoke to the Irish
ambassador um and then he put some
parentheses add roses and the children's
reflections to mine here to flesh things
out a little bit
almost staged notes yeah absolutely and
you know it's the kind of scripting that
I think may have been related to his
early experience in Hollywood but also I
think that one of the most fascinating
things to me about him was that he
certainly was somebody who hitched his
wagon to the growth of new technologies
over the course of the 20th century and
he was particularly interested in media
technologies
and you know got into film very early
got into theater and vaudeville very
early on and was a great was one of the
first practitioners and proponents of
product placement for example he used to
he ran this advertising company in
Boston in the 20s that didn't go very
far but I think it says a lot about his
views about advertising in general in
that the backdrops to the vaudeville
shows would be painted with the signs
and serve insignias and of the companies
whose stocks he traded and while he was
at the same time a stock trader in
Boston and you also see notes from
around the same period thanking priests
and theater managers alike for putting
in some sort of good word either in a
sermon or in the Saturday matinee about
his father-in-law
honey fits his latest candidacy so that
you see that he he begins to see that
publicity generated in any field can
generate favourable notice in any other
field whether it's in church or on a
stage backdrop or anything and so I
think that he was somebody who hitched
his wagon to these new media
technologies and had a real knack for
seeing um how to generate publicity
about himself he was also somebody who I
think is one of the first people to
actually hire a clipping service on his
own behalf and so as he became more
famous as he left Hollywood for example
and his renown over spilled the bounds
of the the trade press in California and
as he went into say the SEC in the
Maritime Commission and began to read of
himself in newspapers across the country
and in cover stories on time for example
or in fortune you begin to see the
effect that that has on his own view of
himself and his willingness to actually
commit things to paper on the one hand
he's a little bit more guarded as he
becomes more famous on the other hand he
begins to see himself as a historical
figure and begins to include these sorts
of notations like you know ad Clare
Boothe Lucis letter here to make things
clearer and that
it was really fascinating the way that
he you know both rode the wave of new
media technologies and was really very
much shaped by it personally is this
history or authorized biography or
something in between as you say these
are annotated letters they are not a
biography per se they're not a narrative
why did you decide to do the book this
way and if it were not in effect an
authorized biography other other things
you would have said or wanted to know
about Joe Kennedy well I wouldn't call
it an authorized biography I mean well
it's authorized in the sense that you're
using his own words about himself and
that's what I'd hope to do I mean one of
the things that I'm most grateful for in
doing this project is that it was really
an amazing education and scholarship for
me and as you were mentioning before one
of the things that struck me most was
that in terms of documents that had been
excerpted or published about him in the
past very often you know leaving out a
single sentence or giving a particular
emphasis to a word that's been chosen as
part of a quotation may or may not
change the context of the document from
which it's lifted and may or may not
reflect differently on the life as a
whole or the spirit of of what was being
said in that particular context and in
the course of reading over his letters
and diaries as I said before I came to
have much more in a nuanced picture of
him um and it seemed to me that although
I'd read a lot of accounts of the family
and and that sort of thing that actually
when I reach uh fold the documents that
I've found in various places into
chronological order they actually read
very much like a novel particularly one
of the things that I tried to do to sort
of demonstrate in some small measure the
expanse of his life and his focuses um
you know ranging from business matters
to his children was to include some of
his children's letters back to him in
part because I think that you can't
really separate out his
official or business correspondence from
his children because the reason he says
over and over again that he created the
life for himself that he did for his
children was to make their emergence
into public life into the civic life of
the country possible and it is letters
back and forth to his children I think
are as characteristic of him as as
anything else perhaps more
characteristic of him so it gives I've
tried to give a sort of expanse of his
whole life and his own words and often
when I was reading accounts that had
been written
based on these letters or paraphrasing
the general account that appears in
these letters I found that actually the
letters themselves were much more
evocative and that's what I wanted to
create and to actually make these
documents available to people who might
be writing biographies about him or
might be just writing about the 20th
century and and used these peripherally
but it seemed to me that the most
important thing was to make these
available to people readily available
not just in an archive someplace in
order to contribute to what it is
possible to know not only about his
family but about the United States you
said you left out letters that were
private correspondence involving private
individuals people who were not public
at the time you categorically left out
people loved it for their own privacy is
there anything you left out from Joe
Kennedy himself
no I think that we'd want to read and I
took it very seriously that I was in an
unusual position both to have access to
his letters but also to be in the
possible position of censoring them and
for that reason I made it clear to
people in the family that there would be
um things described in his
correspondence and diaries that would be
difficult to take particularly if you
consider them written by your own father
and I think that um you know anybody
even flipping through will see very
quickly that although written primarily
by Jack
named by members of his family the
documents aren't by any means
universally flattering to them and I
think that his lapses although he was
somebody who was very self-conscious
about the public image and historical
image that he was creating himself I
think the lapse is where he puts things
down on paper that um you know maybe
with hindsight he might have wished he
hadn't are very fascinating and I think
also the things that he doesn't commit
to paper are in some ways as
characteristic of him as those things
that he does put down on paper and as
revealing in yeah um and so what I
wanted to do was give you know anybody
interested or the reader or the
historian a general sense of him in his
own eyes because that to me was one of
the central components missing from many
biographies about him there's so many
Kennedy cousins why you um that's a good
question I think um at the time I was
really the only person interested in
them and being in graduate school I had
actually came to it and it sort of
roundabout backwards way um my mother
had mentioned to me that her father's
papers were at the JFK Library but
hadn't been processed and I knew a fair
amount about Roe document preservation
so I went to the JFK Library and I
started going through them and the first
thing that struck me wasn't so much the
content but the condition their
condition I mean I was really astonished
and very I'm anxious that the document
should actually be preserved for
posterity
um and going into it I didn't really
have much of a sense of my grandfather
in his own right um and I'd read a lot
about him and I knew the bare bones
outline of his life but I didn't I
didn't have much of a sense of him and I
think I've come to have a sense of him
but um my primary interest was just in
preserving and making sure that these
documents would not deteriorate any
further this is a book about Joe Kennedy
not about Amanda Smith but as one
reviewer said he would have liked to
know more about what it's like to grow
up adopted in a family so driven by
blood in the words of the reviewer is
there anything we should know about that
I don't know I think that I'm sort of
I've often thought of myself as the
poster child for nature winning out over
nurture because although I've grown up
and in this particular family I think
temperamentally a mother a different
creature um and I think that's one of
the reasons that led me to do the book I
think I have a much more introverted
introspective personality than some
people in the family who are much more
outgoing and sort of public characters
and I think that's what led me to want a
career in scholarship and actually we
were discussing before we came on stage
about the enjoyment of actually doing
research by yourself alone and not not
talking to people and that's one of the
things that I really liked about these
letters is that you were interacting
with people who you know over in a sense
that's very close to you
but that you'll never know in your own
right because many of them are dead or
died before you were born
um but reading over the stuff a minute
it comes to inform your view of the way
dead family dynamics have come to evolve
over the course of decades and over the
course of the lives of people that you
know and so in that sense I think it was
very informative to me um how did you
reconcile the the two or the four of the
ten Joe Kennedy's that you came across
in researching this book you said that
you couldn't describe him in one word
and too often he had been described
dismissed denounced hailed by one word
whether it was the king maker or the
bootlegger people always trying to
pigeonhole him in one of those
categories is there word that you would
use to describe him I don't know that I
can't people have asked me that before
and I haven't come up with a single word
to describe him um one word that that
reviewers cited was patriarchy as
someone said you can quarrel with the
vulgarity and infidelity that made
Kennedy a pirate but the fact remains
that he raised three sons who have
shaped u.s. politics for half a cent
he certainly did that yeah he did and
actually one thing I was going to
mention is it's not my word but I was
saying asked my mom the same question
you know how would you describe your
father as a father and her response
actually stopped me in my tracks she
said oh he was really um cozy
I thought cozy but that's just about the
last thing I expected but that really
you know that's as much a part of him as
anything else um and he was you know
like like we all are um very
multifaceted character and I think that
he's been blown up and sort of put
himself in the public stage in such a
way that and had a very you know in many
ways had a kind of had nine lives um so
that it's not possible I think to to sum
him up in a single word any more than
it's possible to sum anybody up in a
single word you said that he struck a
Faustian bargain to allow his precious
children to fulfill his dreams
what was that bargain well actually in
that in that particular sentence I was
writing about the kind of image that I
had taken of him from reading about him
over the years
and I wasn't so much speaking my own
view of him as I was the kind of
generalized view that I had taken on by
reading what other people had read about
him but um I think that in terms of
what's been said about him before
there's a sense that he created this
dynasty and created the drive for his
children to participate in public life
and that these hostages to fortune
that that came back to bite him and you
know that possibly putting them on the
public stage also may have put them in
danger in the end and put him in a
position to lose the things that were
most dear to him and the reason that he
had gone to all the trouble to begin
with to create a fortune to UM over and
over again he talks about taking
government jobs that he wasn't
necessarily satisfied with in Washington
because of the prestige to use his word
that they would confer upon his children
the legitimacy that they would confer
upon his children and so I suppose that
you know the destruction of that is
probably what people meant by this kind
of Faustian bargain that he struck and
fascinating insights into the book from
things that might be considered trivial
and some of great significance but
there's a letter that struck me that Joe
Kennedy wrote to Harry Cohen the
filmmaker it was about the distribution
of mr. Smith goes to Washington which
was being shown abroad I guess at that
point and Joe Kennedy complained to
Harry Cohen he said this film must
inevitably strengthen the mistaken
impression that the United States is
full of graft corruption and lawlessness
and contains very little in politics
that is creditable that from Joe Kennedy
to Harry Cohn about mr. Smith goes to
Washington what is what we see in this
insight into Joe Kennedy tell us about
the way we look at politicians and
public figures today when we view them
through the prism of their personal
foible are we seeing too much of that
should that fade into the background is
that not as important as it ought to be
or do all the things those things add up
and give us a sense of what kind of
character of a lack of a better word the
people who are governing us or would
like to govern us have well I think he's
talking at a very different moment in
time I mean this is 1939 when he writes
this letter and I think it's worth
remembering that the bulk of the
American people didn't realize that
their president had polio and I think
he's speaking of an America that um you
know in part is a very different America
because of the very media technologies
that he um tried to cultivate and make
use of to his own ends over the course
of his life and technologies that
posthumously or even during his lifetime
came back to bite him in the sense that
we know a great deal more about him than
we might have had they not existed and
we know a great deal more about our
presidents and feel our own politicians
in general and feel probably greater
right now to have access to their
personal dealings
but I'm not sure he even envisioned a
Watergate or sometimes I'm sort of
watershed event that brought that about
and I think just you know wanted to
create an image of America that was and
and wanted in America that was as good
as it could be
would he have survived the kind of
scrutiny we give public figures today
well it's interesting you call him a
public figure because I think in some
ways he was had one foot in public life
in one foot in private life I mean
certainly after the falling out with
Roosevelt he retreated into the
background a great deal as you point out
the book did not even plan to publish
his memoirs his diplomatic memoirs for
fear or concerned that it might
embarrass his kids or affect their
political ambitions and she said let
them carry the ball you know it's
interesting about that I mean that's
very often said but one thing that I
found about his um his reluctance to
publish his memoir about his time in
Britain which began as a kind of you
know celebration of the fact that he was
the first Irish American ambassador to
go to London and very quickly as he
began to fall out with Roosevelt and
their disagreement began to drive a
wedge between them over the issue of
neutrality um he began to sort of
document very carefully all of the
slights and insults um and all of the
what he felt were untrue that Roosevelt
was putting forward about exactly his
attitude towards American intervention
over the course of 1939 in 1940 um but
if Joe Kennedy was an isolationist um in
1938 1939 he it's also worth remembering
that he was nice elation estate aid to
Britain which wasn't necessarily
characteristic of say the America first
movement but he became I think a much
more staunch isolationist over the
course of the 40s and 50s um he gave a
speech in 1941 that the title of the
book comes from hostage to or 1940
where he said that I can't agree with
the general isolationist um but then by
1950 he gives a speech at the University
of Virginia Law School where he says you
know if isolationism means taking care
of your own and thinking about yourself
first then you know by god I'm an
isolationist and I think that he was
absolutely unapologetic about his
attitude towards the war and about his
attitudes on foreign policy generally
and his what he says about why he didn't
publish his memoir in the end wasn't so
much embarrassment over his own views as
it was he felt that he was a much more
well-known and significant figure than
his sons and didn't want to steal their
thunder for Amanda Smith sighs copies of
her books for you we'll take questions
from the audience if there are any just
please go up to the microphone in either
side and feel free to ask whatever you'd
like yes ma'am no yes sir you mentioned
the rather tense feelings between Oh Joe
Kennedy and Henry Morgenthau the
Secretary of the treasure now do you
know anything what would have been his
feelings about Jose morgenthau plan' on
the economic dismemberment of Germany at
the close of the pour of the war in 45 I
wish I could find a the quotation and
find something oh there's a direct
quotation where he says I'm words to the
effect of this is the stupidest plan
I've ever heard of in my life and
Morgenthau is I've always thought as an
idiot it goes more or less like that and
he felt that the morgenthau plan' had
actually cost a great deal more lives
for those of you who may or may not be
familiar with it it was a plan to
demilitarize and make into sort of an
agrarian state the former Reich and it
was felt at the time that
German resistance was greater at the end
of the war and a lot more allied lives
were lost because Germans were fighting
harder to keep the morgenthau plan' from
going into effect i'm said that
basically that's what it what he felt
about it and i mean certainly his views
on the morgenthau plan were not
uncolored by his views about Morgenthau
himself and he was opposed to an
unconditional the demands for an
unconditional surrender yes ma'am I was
just curious to know if there was
anything in the book and his letters
that gave you some insight into what
influences if any your grandmother had
on his thinking and his life well that's
a really interesting question I'm glad
you asked that because um I included a
lot of her letters to him also and one
of the things that astonished me most
was that you know whatever may have
taken place outside of their marriage or
in it one of the most poignant periods I
think in the correspondence is late 1939
and 1940 which was the period obviously
after Ward been declared in Europe in
September of 39 and the Kennedy family
with the exception of old Joe Kennedy
and rosemary Kennedy stayed in England
and the rest of the family went home and
although it was a very trying period for
all of them it's a wonderful period in
terms of the correspondence because it
forced them to write to one another and
one of the things that surprised me most
was not only the degree of affection
that he showed in his letters I mean I
think being bereft of his family really
shows you how important they were to him
any laments every-night writes to her
absolutely faithfully every day saying
you know you're the most beautiful woman
in the world and I love you so much and
it's only now that you're gone that I
realize how much you all mean to me um
but the other aspect of that is I didn't
realize the degree to what she was a
sort of political confidant and advisor
to him I mean it's worth remembering
that her father was the former mayor of
Boston and she had great political
instincts and came from in a certainly
political background and
when grandpa came home from London he
had a very tense meeting with Franklin
Roosevelt at which Roosevelt eventually
persuaded him to give this third term
election speech on Roosevelt's behalf a
few days later and I in the period
leading up to that my grandmother had
gone to visit various friends and
consultants of my grandfather to figure
out what grandpa should do about
Roosevelt he was very angry at him at
that point and her advice to him was I
think very good advice which was you
know remember he made your public who
were possible you owe him a great deal
and you know whatever your personal
feelings are about him there's no reason
to cross them he's done a great deal for
you
and that was advice that he followed up
to a certain point um but not entirely
yes sir would you be willing to tell us
anything about the relationship between
your mother and father of relationship
of your mother and father to Joseph
Kennedy and also can you tell us
anything about the sources of his wealth
um of my mother and father to Jessica
well my mother was his daughter yes I
know that but I want to know when she
had a cozy relationship how they got
along what what then did you learn about
him from your mother and father well I
mean I learned about him I think in the
way that many children learn about their
grandparents um and I think that you
know probably the way that all children
know their parents is is not in terms of
their business dealings or you know that
Daddy was chairman of the SEC or daddy
was the ambassador I mean the types of
stories that I heard about at home when
I was growing up were you know that for
example my mother's cousins were
orphaned when they were quite young and
so you know in addition to the nine kids
at home there were another few kids who
came in to live with them and you know I
always heard stories about generosity to
people in need people that he kept up
with from East Boston throughout his
life um
philanthropy and also stories where he
you know came down sort of hard on his
children there's a story that I think is
very telling
him arranging to meet his daughter
Kathleen at 21 for lunch and she was
late and she met him coming out of the
revolving door and after that she wasn't
really late anymore um and also very you
know sweet stories that I still love
when I was a kid you know eating
asparagus with our fingers my mother
would always say um you know our parents
told us never to eat asparagus with our
fingers but um there was nothing much
that they could say after the king and
queen came to dinner and the Queen ate
or asparagus with their fingers so I
mean we heard great stories like that um
and so that's why it was sort of a
surprise to find that other people had
different views as I was growing up and
my father was um was from Brooklyn and
his own father had died when he was five
years old and I was got the sense that
um you know he had taken grandpa very
much as his own father when he got
married he really became part of a new
family and I mean he told me once that
he felt very much that my mother's
brothers were really his brothers and
his best friends so I think that you
know it was a very close family and in
the book Amanda does talk about the
sources of Joe Kennedy's wealth whether
it was bootlegging or stocks just before
the Depression as a banker and of course
starting off at the shipyard just
outside of Boston as well yes sir I just
have a two-part question I read what I
thought was a wonderful biography on
your grandfather called the founding
father I think the author was whaling
mm-hmm and I was wondering what's he
thought of that biography and then
second with regards to the different
facets of Joe Kennedy's life whether was
banking or in the movie business
the one consistent theme I I thought was
that he was very independent he didn't
seem to have a large group of friends
that he he would trust and I was
wondering aside from family or his
personal staff there were a few personal
confidence that he did have throughout
the course of his life that we just
don't know about
yeah he did definitely um and one of his
sort of pithy little phrases about how
to live your life was you know if you
finish your life and you can count
you're really close good friends on the
fingers of one hand you're doing very
well
and I think that you've picked that up I
mean that was certainly true of him and
the people that he was closest to ranged
I mean he had people who were quite
close to him but maybe not as confidants
people who shared interests like William
Randolph Hearst or Lord Beaverbrook um
he was very close to Beaverbrook and
Hearst in the sense that he shared
political opinions with them but I think
the people closest to him were aside
from his children were basically people
who worked with him throughout his life
one guy who comes to mind immediately is
a fella called anymore
who was his sort of right-hand man who
had been an aide to his father-in-law
honey Fitz in Boston and then came to
work for Joe Kennedy and was so close in
fact that um he named his youngest child
after him edward moore kennedy but there
were a number of four or five as you say
men like edward moore but not quite as
closest as moore and who were with him
throughout his life and as for Whelan's
biography I think it's in many ways
really superb uh it was written very
early in 1964 and it I think there's
something really momentous about first
biographies because you know the sources
aren't established for things and Whelan
did a really great job of particularly
in the political and public aspects of
Joe's Joe Kennedy's life I think the
things that he didn't really have access
to were family materials and so that
gets a little bit murkier and hazy er
but um you know the real focus of the
biography is on Joe Kennedy's public
life and I think he does a great job
with that and has been a great source
for anybody else interested in Joe
Kennedy one of the things that Amanda
Smith's book reminds us is that in this
age of people talking on the phone so
much and having personal conversations a
lot of that paper trail of
letter-writing is gone
maybe it'll be resurrected somehow
either electronically or archival II
through email which is not quite the
same thing as much more conversational
than letter-writing is but you wonder
what historian
will do decades from now trying to sort
through the kind of material that Amanda
had the benefit of sorting through this
time even though it meant that have
seemed that on every occasion when you
were up to page 300,000 or 400,000 yes
sir let's take two quick last questions
I've heard a good deal this evening
about Joe Kennedy the family man the
loving father etc I haven't heard only a
little bit about his philandering I
wonder how your grandmother accepted
that it's not really clear I mean one of
the things that I was saying before is
that I think that the gaps in his
correspondence are in many ways as
characteristic of him as what he
actually commits to paper there were a
number of letters in fact that you quote
the book - Gloria Swanson's husband but
not necessarily anything other than
business matters - Gloria Swanson yeah I
mean he whatever was going on there he
you know I suppose like anybody who
might or might not have been having
affairs um I don't think would stand
anybody in good stead to document it
particularly well and so insofar as he
documented his own life and there really
isn't anything to to hold up there I
just wondered about your grandmother's
response to all this and she didn't
write it down either yeah she didn't
write it down
yes sir Miss Smith you mentioned your
shock when you got access to the papers
at the condition they were in and I know
myself several years ago I inquired
about the papers and found that they
were not actually formally donated to
the library and therefore the archivists
had no authority to process them
conservator them inventory them or make
them available has that situation
changed you expect yes yes and actually
one of the things that I'd hope to do
with the papers was preserve them at
least long enough so that I along with a
number of other people who were really
dedicated to it could persuade the
family to give them to the National
Archives and that
done and insofar as I collected things
and amassed them and tried to preserve
them I gave it all to the library so
everything I have is there now and one
of the problems as you point out with
the papers is that a lot of them are
carbon copies of letters and though that
flimsy carbon paper copy just didn't
last as well as fine paper might have
yeah it's very fragile but as you know
I'm sure but um my understanding is and
once I gave the papers I felt that my
role was more or less done there but my
understanding is that there are a number
of scholars including Robert Dalek you
probably know who we're working with the
papers now so if you have an interest in
getting to them I'd say apply again to
the JFK Library yes ma'am um does did
Joe Kennedy ever give an opinion as to
who assassinated Jack Kennedy well I
think it's worth remembering that he had
a stroke in late 1961 and which really
incapacitated him until his death in
1969 and he wasn't really able to speak
um although he one reviewer pointed out
that he would frequently after the
stroke moan the word no I'm not sure if
that's true or not but that is part of
the Kennedy legend is there any sense
what he was referring to um not that I
know of I mean he as far as I know he
actually was able to say slightly more
than now um but uh I'm not sure what his
reaction was to it and just when that
question was there the Joe Kennedy ever
give his other sons an opinion as to
whether they should continue in public
life for example well Ted Kennedy yeah
actually I mean even from a very early
age there's a letter that is I think
really astonishing um in the sense that
it was written in
September of 1942 Ted when he was eight
years old and it describes the Blitz and
I think it's it's a very interesting
letter in terms of a how you describe
devastation like that to a small child
but there's a section of it where he
says you know now there are thousands of
people bombed out of their homes
children are being taken to the country
to protect them and I know if you were
here you'd be very brave but one thing I
want you to remember is that I hope that
you dedicate your life to making things
better for people and not creating havoc
click the Germans are doing right now
and so even you know when he was a very
tiny child as as grandpa did with all
the children there was this sort of
civic message that you know you should
be involved in the life of your country
even to an eight-year-old yeah the book
is hostage to fortune the letters of
Joseph P Kennedy edited by Amanda Smith
she'll be around to sign copies of the
book and thank you for coming
you